the first comedian to bring to the stage
of your screen
is uh is on a quite literally right now
i think on the set
of uh upload which is original amazon
series by the creators of the office
zanab johnson hey moses
is that what you're shooting right now
can you say yeah yeah i'm in vancouver
right now
and i'm not actually on set but i am
uh next door in the production office in
one of their spaces
because the wi-fi in my trailer sucked
how was it
one shooting something in a lockdown
because a lot of the fun
of being on set is that it's more social
than stand up
it's good to hang out with everyone but
now there's this almost weird
protective coat on everything you know
what kovitt i thought that covid was
going to
make the like day-to-day things really
sort of annoying
um i thought it was going to add a lot
of business to the already
businessy things you have to do and it
doesn't like you get
pretty used to it i have one of my masks
right next to me
so i'm so used to putting this on and
off um
it's nothing the thing that's like um
you know can cause like anxiety is in
vancouver you get like zones
and the zones define like how often you
get tested
so you know there's different zones for
different people which is some
weird future [ __ ] of like you're a group
a
and it's like i want to be a yeah no it
totally feels i am legend
it totally feels like the beginning of
the end
yeah i think the travel ban really helps
you know like
the us and i love the us but the us was
like
we don't care come and go as you please
you know
and canada is still not like that when i
first got here i had to do a 14 day
quarantine and they were serious
like calling me every single day sending
emails i had to check in
the neighbors like the moment i opened
the door for instacart the neighbors
were also out there like
we dare you to take one foot out that
door
i even did a virtual fitting where they
had all the clothes delivered to my
apartment
and i was on the phone with a covet
operator from the government
and she heard the wardrobe stylist on a
zoom call
and she was like hold on a second is
that someone else in your background
it doesn't say that you've traveled with
anyone and i was like relaxed lady
it's zoom you're hearing
yeah no one has that terrible robot
voice of zoom audio cut out
yeah i mean they take i know people that
have gotten the full fine i mean there's
a hundred and sixty thousand dollar fine
yeah this person was doing like two
lines on something
so wait you know they gotta find yeah
and they they actually
in vancouver they're serious about it
yeah they're super serious about it they
saw someone
go to a grocery store that was on a set
that shall not be named
paramount plus and then here it's just
like wear your mask
anywhere on your face and then that's
fine i mean some states have removed the
mask mandate at this point i like the
mask that you have it's the one for
actors so it doesn't mess up
your hair so it's essentially it goes
around your neck right
it's a trough it feels like you should
put food in there
and then just throughout the day eat
your way out i love it because it's
always like a button to a conversation
you know how we used to be able to hang
up flip phones
whenever i've made a point at the end of
the point i'm like and i'm done
it's very satisfying and i like how you
were talking to that person with your
mask down
the entire time just spraying kobe kobe
kovitt no more coping
i'm not a germaphobe at all but it's
hard when they keep showing us these
very disturbing graphics of like here's
how much spray comes off of someone
and then like how are we gonna cope
after this if you and i are talking and
i'm just gonna be thinking about these
computer graphics of just
my stuff coming off oh i'm never going
back to normal i'm standing six feet
apart from everybody i'm wearing a mask
everywhere i don't care this is a new
normal
i i know what spit does now no more
wet handshakes with people no i don't
want to do that i definitely don't want
to hug you
i've seen how many people protest about
hand washing like i gotta wash my hands
again i'm
like oh my god i'm never coming to your
house again
next i gotta wipe my butt you should
want to do that just for you
but is it nice to just be back around
people and socializing and essentially
have an excuse
under the guidelines of like i'm working
yeah it feels really good to be back at
work i mean we
you know this we all like stand up took
a dive
you know so for me just even as a
creative person it feels like i'm
finding that i'm having so much fun on
set
and i'm i'm not afraid to try things and
i think it's because
i'm missing the performance of stanza
and so now every time i get in the scene
i'm like i got
jokes because you just do it how it's
written i'm like but i got
jokes i got a joke if you can get a
laugh from a cashier at a grocery store
oh sat
for the week yeah i think one of the
last things that
i did like one of the second to last-ish
big events is
you and i were in chicago and we we did
those pogo shows for the
nba all-star game unwittingly hosting a
super spreader event
unknowingly unknowingly unknowing i saw
photos pop
up and like how iphone makes you feel
bad and there's like memories from last
year i'm just looking at all the people
i'm like oh no
but that was such a great way to go out
right if
you had to choose what your last kind of
event was going to be before a lockdown
like
that was amazing right that was a fun
show it wasn't like i did the flappers
yoo-hoo room
yeah no 6am on a sunday my hotel i went
up in my like every morning every night
i was seeing professional nba players
for me i'm like this is
this is the way this is pregame a
lockdown
yeah and it was nice to not be like
usually if it's a comedy festival
there's a lot of pressure on comedian
this is nice because like we're the side
thing we're like the side of that
everyone's here for the nba
and if they're too drunk to be in that
game they come heckle us at this show
yeah you've been doing your your podcast
just friends
is that how you're keeping up with
performing just talking in front of
people or are you trying to do these
outdoor
or even zoom shows i do two podcasts so
i do honesty with z
um which is just me and i rant about the
world oh that's
great and just friends is another
podcast that i do with another comedian
and that's like relationship so we talk
all relationship stuff we talk about
everything marriage being single sex we
answer questions
it's fun you guys saw the live one you
did on sunday i was watching live
and people had questions have you
noticed the questions have gotten a
little weirder as people have had
less time to date and more time to spend
alone
yes i don't know they're almost like too
too much to the point they don't coat
them at all
i think also too you have a lot of
people who when they're talking to
comedians they really try and jazz up
their questions
you know like they really try to write
their best
joke but the reality is you see a lot of
people are lonely like people answer
their own question
in the question like this guy cheated on
me four times but he made me laugh the
other day should i be with him it's like
what you have the answer yeah
you know you wrote the answer down i'm
like girl he did not make you laugh this
is a pandemic
you looking for something funny like
everything is right right
yeah your list of like would never has
severely gone down
exactly exactly so season two of upload
is coming
tbd yeah season one is available on
amazon right now
you of course are the two great podcasts
or at least great names honestly
can't i wanted to name my podcast ad
people said it doesn't make any sense
you did it talks to zainab and she just
tells him the truth
yeah it's easy we could switch it all
right well thank you
thank you for chat with us thanks for
having me